[Musique]
par les enfants
les parfums de la campagne sont bien
agréables falloir
leur embauche d'une senteur d'herbes
sauvages
bon eh bien je descends var mes petits
sauvages part de mes petits lapins mais
non que je suis bête en mes petits amis
bureau pop hip hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop
je vous jure un lapin gâtés un animal de
la sorte 5
on déménage pas du tout mon cher
nounours voyez plutôt c'est la maison de
monsieur n'à pas en lait très bien vous
trouvez j'avais peur que cornichons ne
les installer dans son lit cela ne
saurait tarder mon cher
salut et voilà des carottes fraîches
pour le petit lapin bravo cornichons
cette maison de lapin est très
confortable mais c'est zizou quelques
jours le temps qu'il s'habitue vous jure
l'a pas dit puisque tu aimes et garonne
car monsieur un difficile mais c'est un
même mode adorent et la db c'est
toujours difficile surtout quand on
occupe trop
[Musique]
enfin passons vous avez raison dada il
ne faut pas lui donner de mauvaises
habitudes
[Musique]
comme
ça il est gâté dante est pourri oui oh
oui cornichons on ne donne pas à manger
un enfant à n'importe quelle heure oui
il faut être très strict sellerie lui
apprendre à respecter les heures des
repas exactement il faut que ce petit
lapin reçoivent une bonne éducation ils
sachent se tenir
dans le monde en effet tu quoi nous non
sa raison ce lapin doit apprendre de
belles manières
m'apprendre pepel madian de lapin il va
aller à l'école était la paire dames à
travers
la montagne et t'as raison pepita tient
le voilà il va retourner auprès de sa
maman dans la forêt
oui mais oui moi en liberté et même
s'ils rentrent à dire bonjour avec
michou
pourvoir belin peu à bientôt
ben là
eh bien c'est ce qui pouvait arriver de
mieux à cela pas c'est parce que tu
disais
il ya bonne nuit cornichons au revoir
tata
béni
tout est bien qui finit bien
[Musique]
gagner notre nounours au patron je suis
content la vie est belle vous ne trouvez
pas oui nounours la vie est très belle
on y vend en route
ni les enfants photo bourrin paul paul
bulcke
[Musique]
oh
et
[Applaudissements]
enfants
on
[Musique]